les jardins communautaires sont endormis
l'hiver a repris ses droits sur Montréal
mais à l'abri des regards et du froid
des légumes verts poussent
tranquillement en profitant du soleil
leur unique source de chaleur
6,5
verdure asiatique on a de la laitue des
boxsissent le mieux au froid puis même
qui sont meilleurs après un ou deux gel
ils deviennent plus sucrés pour seuls
indices de cette expérience agricole
quelques affiches colorées et trois
abris d'auto les seuls abris d'auto qui
soient permis dans l'arrondissement
Ville-Marie on est dans l'arrondissement
Ville-Marie dans le quartier centres sud
on est vraiment tout près de
centre-ville n'est vraiment quelque
chose à petit échelle pour tester les
serres passives à énergie passive en
fait au Québec dans un métropole qui est
très très froide
on est dans une rue donc sur la soif il
y a aucune sœur qui est chauffée c'est
le deuxième hiver où les organismes le
carrefour solidaire et le laboratoire
sur l'agriculture urbaine expérimente la
culture en serre non chauffée
extrême vraiment les plantes avaient la
mine basse puis au courant de la journée
quand il faisait soleil et reprenait
dans la même journée il fait soleil et
finalement ça redevient tout vert et
cette année ce qui est cool c'est que
pour l'instant l'hiver est plutôt doux
apprenant des erreurs du passé on a fait
les semis plutôt et sur place
de cette année
avec une quarantaine d'exploitations
commerciales et une centaine de jardins
communautaires Montréal fait bonne
figure en agriculture urbaine puis
surtout c'est comme pas mal inscrit dans
les politiques publiques c'est une vraie
volonté de la Ville de développer
secteur qui a plein de bénéfices
forcément on parle de production
alimentaire ça donne accès à des légumes
sains aux citoyens c'est vraiment ici
que ce commence la promenade des saveurs
les trois serres sont un plus pour ce
site qui abrite en été un potager en pot
ou les citoyens peuvent faire de
l'auto-caillère une plus de 300
personnes le par semaine qui viennent
dans le jardin plus modeste les récoltes
divers se retrouvent dans les repas
communautaires destinés aux familles
dans le besoin mais on voit grand
elle s'affine ici Radio-Canada Montréal